I want to talk about my mentor.
I want to talk about the day
that I got a phone call
saying that he had died.
And I want to talk about the moments
later in the same phone call
that I'd heard that he'd actually
taken his own life.
And I'm saying this
because I want you to listen
and also think about all the people
that you love and adore
and you cannot imagine
living without in your life
as you're listening to me talk.
My friend, my mentor,
my father figure, Angus.
I truly loved him.
My father had left the family home
when I was quite young,
and he took on the mantle
to look after me.
I'd known him from a very young age,
he taught me how to swim.
He was my cousin's boyfriend
then my cousin's husband,
and he was just my go-to guy.
When I was starting to date girls
and I wasn’t sure what to do,
I'd ring him up and I'd ask him,
"Mate, what do you think?
What's going on?
How should I perhaps do this?"
When I ended up working for him
years and years later
in a big multi-corporate,
I'd always go to him for workarounds,
"How can I get this deal done?"
He always seem to be that guy
that I could turn to,
and he would always give me
the right answer.
Not only me, I remember walking
around the corner at work one day
and there's always someone in his office.
There was always someone waiting for him,
if you rang him up, he was always
on the phone, he'd ring you back.
He always seemed to be that guy
that had people going to him,
asking for help,
asking for favors, asking for support.
He was good-looking.
Beautiful wife, my cousin.
Three beautiful children.
Why would someone like that
take their own life?
Why would they?
Makes no sense to me.
And at the funeral,
and talking to people after the funeral,
just the frustration,
"Did you know?" "Did you know?"
"Did anyone know?" "Did you get a clue?"
And of course everyone's saying,
"No, I didn't have a clue.
In fact, he was just like you're saying,
he was my go-to guy."
He seemed to tick all the boxes.
He seemed to just know
what to say at the right time,
and he seemed to be able to work his way,
both personally and with work,
to get life done.
And he was successful.
I told that story
on a breakfast show that I was on
called "The Grill Team"
in Sydney, Australia.
I was on there for 11 years.
And one morning,
I decided to be vulnerable.
One morning I said, "Do you know what?
I'm going to talk about my friend."
Because we were six years
into that 11-year stint,
and I'd never really spoken
much about myself.
We spoke about sport,
we spoke about telling jokes.
We did things like ticket giveaways
and concert giveaways and fun stuff.
We wanted to get people driving to work
or listening to us having fun.
We didn't want to sort of drag them down
with personal stuff or being vulnerable.
But one morning, 4:30 in the morning,
sitting around the production table
with the producers and my cohost, I said,
"I'm going to be vulnerable today.
I'm going to talk about something
that I haven't spoken about before,
and it's been eating away at me
and I want to do it."
And they supported me.
We've been on for a long time,
we were like brothers.
We said, "You know what?
Whatever you want to do, let's go for it."
So 8:05 just after the eight o'clock news,
the Hollywood hour in radio land,
we flicked on the mics,
and I told the story
that I just told you guys.
It was hard.
I was getting support from my cohost,
I got the words out eventually,
a bit like I am today.
Emotional stuff,
certain things trigger you.
But what was truly happening behind me
was all the phone lines
into the radio station were flashing,
which means people were phoning in.
Normally those lines would be for you
to ring up to be part of the show,
to tell a joke, to win a concert ticket,
to win a movie ticket.
All of a sudden,
all those lines were flashing.
Didn't quite realize why.
The producer comes in and says,
"We've got all these people that want
to thank you for telling your story."
I thought, that's nice.
I've put myself out there,
It is nice to get
a little bit of love like that.
So we started putting a few calls through.
Not only were they telling me,
"Thank you for telling that story,"
more importantly,
it was like we'd given them a green light,
we'd given them permission
to talk about the stuff
that they wanted to talk about.
All of a sudden, in a safe place,
like a radio station where they'd normally
laugh their way to work,
we'd given them a little opportunity
to talk about the stuff
that's truly important to them,
the stuff that they had in their bellies,
the stuff banging around in their heads
that they never thought they would get
a chance to talk about.
So what we did for the next 90 minutes
was just the most beautiful radio
that I've ever been involved in.
We took no traffic reports,
no news reports,
we played no music,
we just had 90 minutes
of people bumbling and fumbling
and getting their way through
a conversation of gravity
with us in the radio studio.
There was moments --
Thank you.
(Applause)
It was impressive
that so many people went,
"You know what, I'm diving in here.
I'm talking about my stuff now
because he spoke about that,"
all strangers listening
to each other on the radio
all gave each other permission
to have a chat.
There was moments of true silence,
and silence in radio is not a good thing.
However, when you have silence
when you can sort of hear the tears,
you can try to just hear them gathering
the guts and determination
to say the next word.
Or you can basically hear the snot
running out of the nose
and the tears running out of the eyes,
that's when you know,
people are being fair dinkum,
that's when you know
that they're being real.
So, fantastic.
And it made me think.
I wonder how many other people
are worrying alone?
If we just opened it up on this radio show
on this morning and I tell my story,
then we have 90 minutes of people going,
"Me too," "Me too," "Me too,"
I wonder how many people are out there
feeling exactly the same way.
So that day changed my life.
I decided to commit myself
to being more honest, more vulnerable.
But even more importantly, let's get
suicide prevention down to zero.
A huge call, I know, and I said
it in the Australian press
and everyone gave it to me,
but I don't care.
I'm going to focus
on making sure that no one goes
through the type of stuff
that my mate went through.
And how do we do that?
How do we do that?
That's the trick.
So for the last six years,
I’ve been running a foundation
called “Gotcha4Life.”
I want everyone in the world to find
someone who has got you for life.
Someone you can talk to, warts and all,
without any fear of judgment,
about the truly important stuff.
Why do we keep celebrating
with lots of people in parties
but we don't celebrate the stuff
that's a little bit harder,
the stuff that's not so good?
Why is that the case?
So that's been the focus.
I don't know if you know
the stats around suicide.
I think we're all big enough
and ugly enough in here to know them.
In Australia, seven men
every day, two women;
nine Australians that woke up this morning
won't wake up tomorrow morning.
65,000 people in Australia try to take
their own life every single year.
The number one way to die,
if you’re a young Australian male,
is suicide.
Now, according to the World
Health Organization, WHO,
they tell me that over 1,900 people
that woke up this morning
won't wake up tomorrow morning.
They would have taken their own life.
On top of that, 38,000,
nearly 40,000 people
will try to take their own life today.
1,900 people today.
38,000 will attempt today
around the world.
Now, I don't know you guys very well,
but I'm sure, in the last couple of days
I've got the vibe and the love
that we are all here to try
and make the world a better place.
So this is not what we're going to accept.
This is a line in the sand,
time to go, "No, no more."
But what can you do?
If you look at the world
as this huge, big place,
it might be too big a task
for you to deal with.
It might be too big in your own country.
It might be too big in your own city.
But what if we just started looking
after your own village?
What if we just say, "I'm just going
to look after my own people,
the people that I love and adore
and I cannot imagine living without?"
Just imagine that.
In the last few years,
I've been so lucky to talk to people
that have tried to take their life,
but they're still with us.
Now those conversations are hard.
I feel extremely blessed to be able
to be in those one-on-one conversations.
You know what comes out
of those conversations?
Three things.
One, they didn't want to die.
They tried to take their own life,
but they didn't want to die.
That gave me great hope.
The other thing was that they were tired,
and they were in pain.
So if you combine tired and pain together,
you make a shit decision.
We all know this.
If you are not rested
and you're in pain, you make bad calls.
So if we know that they don't want to die,
but they've tried to take their life,
that's the hope
that we need to hold on to.
That means if we can get to people
before they get to an eight, nine
out of ten in terms of how they feel,
we can actually stop them
making that permanent decision
based on a temporary situation.
That's what it's all about.
And that's what I want to do
with you guys now, if I possibly can.
Just in the small amount
of time I got left,
I want you to trust me
that I'm going to put my big bear hug,
and if you knew me well, I'd be hugging
all of you if I possibly can.
I'm a hugger.
(Laughter)
COVID really knocked me for six.
(Applause)
No hugging in COVID was no good.
What I'd love you to do
is just all of you,
shut your eyes for me, please.
No one else can see you,
so please roll along.
We're going to shut our eyes.
I want you to think of someone
that you love and adore
and you cannot imagine living without.
Have you got that person's
face in your head?
Do you know what that person’s name is,
and have you got them locked in?
Now open your eyes.
After three, I want you to shout
that person's name out.
One, two, three.
(Audience shouting)
OK, this is the bit.
Over the next two and a half days,
I'm going to be haunting you,
I'm going to be cuddling you,
I'm looking after you, I'm coming for you.
I'm coming for everyone in this theater.
You need to do something for me
to that person that you just shouted out.
I need you to send them a text message.
Simple as that.
Having these face-to-face
conversations, I understand, is hard.
But when we're building
our mental fitness,
as already been mentioned
in this session,
we have to start slowly.
So I want you to walk up
to the mental fitness gym for me
and just open up those doors,
and I want you to send a text.
But the words to the text are this:
“I love you, I miss you,
See you soon xoxo.”
Hopefully you can remember that.
I'll be outside if you want
to get -- or ask someone,
I'm sure someone's going to remember.
What I want you to do
is send that text message,
and let's just see what responses we get.
As I said, I’ll be hunting you down
over the next two and a half days,
and I want you to run up to me and go,
"I've got the text, here's my response."
I want other people who go,
"Oh, here's that bloke,
I'm going to walk away."
I'm going to hunt you down.
And the reason I'm doing that
is because I want everyone just to have
a little bit of connection with the person
that is most important to you,
that person that you thought about
straight away as you shut your eyes
and went, "OK, that's my person."
It's all about connection.
It's all about making sure
that you look after the people
the people that are most important to you.
Work can wait.
It'll always be there,
they'll always replace you.
But not these people.
I would give anything
to have a cup of tea, a beer,
go to a footy match with my man
who took his own life.
I'll never be able to do that.
Let's make sure
that we look after our village.
Make sure we look after the people
that are most important to you.
That is absolutely key.
The worst thing?
The text message gets sent out,
someone goes, "What the --"
(Laughter)
Or, "Are you drunk?"
Or if a man sends it to a man,
there will be a phone call
within 30 seconds, guaranteed.
(Laughter)
Or the worst case scenario?
"What's this all about?"
Well, you can then say to them,
"Well, I was asked to think of someone
that I love and adore
and can't imagine living without.
I thought of you."
That's a pretty cool way
to connect yourself up
with the people that are most
important to you.
Thanks so much for listening, guys,
I appreciate it.
(Applause and cheers)